emmanuelle cosse la secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir soirée merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
trois grandes questions comme chaque
semaine 1 êtes vous convaincu par le
plan emploi détaillé par françois
hollande hier on ne vous a pas encore
entendu fa les mesures annoncées par le
chef de l'état de faut-il une primaire
de la gauche pour un seul candidat en
2017 au ps à l'elysée on semble
désormais dire oui à mais à certaines
conditions vous répondrais sur ce sujet
à lucile malandain enfin troisième
question pollution des moteurs diesel
peut-on faire confiance aux
constructeurs automobiles
arnaud mais également aux autres renault
qui reconnaît une erreur mais qu'est la
messe de public sénat vous interrogera
tout à l'heure première question donc
emmanuelle cosse les annonces du chef de
l'état ont été accueillis on peut le
dire dans un climat de scepticisme est
ce que vous vous êtes convaincus par le
plan emploi de françois hollande
écoutez la première chose c'est que je
pense extrêmement important que ce plan
a été présenté et que la mobilisation de
ce gouvernement soit vraiment sur
l'emploi je pense qu'il y avait une
urgence et je regrette mois que sap a
été plutôt qu' on est des propositions
de la sorte après vous l'avais dit il ya
un scepticisme parce qu'en fait il ya un
peu de tout dans ce plan là et je pense
qu'en même temps
moi j'attends d'un gouvernement quel
qu'il soit d'ailleurs qui immobilise
très forte auprès des personnes qui sont
en recherche d'emploi qui sont inquiètes
pour le maintien de leur emploi quand le
laonnois
donc tout ce qui est annoncé sur la
formation me semble extrêmement
important parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de personnes ont du mal à changer
d'emploi ou en prendre un pour des
problèmes de défaillance de formation ne
découvre pas aujourd'hui oui mais je
pense qu'il ya si vous vous laissez pas
une recette sur la formation vous faites
une fois que tout va bien à la
population active elle bouge les
demandes des professions bouge aussi le
métier du bâtiment d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas celui d'hier le métier du numérique
n'existait pas il ya quelques années
donc c'est quelque chose en mouvement il
est normal de s'adapter et donc d'aller
aussi vers des filières où il ya des
besoins très fort en emploi des besoins
de formation les bons notation après
l'autre chose c'est qu'on revient tous
même s'il ya l'autre grande mesure qui
est la question des aides
en 2001 pour la création de deux euros
et puis la création d'emplois à des
niveaux à peu près liés au smic
et là la grande difficulté c'est qu'on
revient un peu au débat qu'on a depuis
en fait cinq ans notamment sur le cic et
sur d'autres mesures c'était tout le
temps sur des mesures macro on est tous
le monde
alors comment la question à laquelle
j'aimerais qu'à un moment nous répondent
en particulier monsieur gattaz ils sont
où les 1 million d'emplois qui nous a
promis il ya eu c'est ici il ya eu un
pacte de responsabilité ya le pacte de
stabilité il ya eu beaucoup des deux
entreprises
ça a été fait nous en avons à l'époque
nous dit qu'il n'y avait aucune
conditionnalité à ces aides et c'était
un problème c'est que le patronat tarder
j'estime et patronat après les études de
fc2 d'autres études qui ont été montrées
a pu reconstituer ses marges de man
beaucoup d'entreprises vont mieux
elles ont pu retrouver une santé
financière même redonner des marges de
manoeuvre à leurs actionnaires
par contre les sujets sur lesquels nous
étions qui était est ce que vous allez
créer des emplois est ce que vous allez
pérenniser les emplois est ce que vous
en profitez pour améliorer les salaires
versés sont des sujets sur lesquels le
patronat ne jamais aller donner encore
vu l'offensive qui était la semaine
dernière d'avoir un nouveau contrat de
travail et donc ne jamais répondre à la
question qui est posée c'est puisque
vous dites vous chefs d'entreprise que
vous êtes les moteurs la création
d'emplois donnez nous des réponses à
cette création là et c'est pour ça qu'à
un moment je pense quand même que l'état
doit aussi un moment posé des conditions
aujourd'hui vous réclamer des comptes au
patronat on réclame des comptes et y
compris de comprendre pourquoi les
accords de branche ont été si peu
nombreux pourquoi où sont les emplois
qui auraient dû être crédit au cic eux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait de cet argent
c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
plusieurs milliards d'euros sur
plusieurs années donc je pense qu'ils
ont des comptes à rendre ce sont les
écrasent les et que les emplois qu'ils
voulaient créer sur les territoires et
c'est pour ça que j'en viens aux
propositions on a eu la cote 21 il ya
maintenant un mois qui aujourd'hui mais
des engagements des états sur la
question du dérèglement climatique qui
veut dire derrière des évolutions dans
notre manière de consommer de se
développer
d'être mobile et donc notamment de
voyager dans notre pays ça veut dire
aussi derrière des emplois locaux et la
question est ce que demain on a dans ce
plan un poids une déclinaison de ses
engagements sur le plan d'eau est ce que
vous pensez qu'il va pouvoir
effectivement créer des postes dans
notre pays est ce que vous pensez que
les mesures annoncées peuvent aboutir à
ce résultat rien au jeu vous le voit
sourire n'est pas convaincu je vais vous
dire pourquoi je vais sourire parce qu
on a droit souvent un ce discours qui
nous expliquent sans croissance on crée
pas d'emplois qui montre bien que être
uniquement sur la logique de la
croissance ne permet pas de répondre à
une question quel emploi est ce que je
vous dis ensuite c'est que je pense
qu'on peut créer des emplois dans des
secteurs qui sont en mouvement qui sont
nouveaux notamment les filières dites
d'avenir quand vous vous engage leur
vraiment non mais c'est très important
plutôt que de nous faire des petits
plans sur des secteurs si on disait
vraiment demain on s'engage pour 40 ans
c'est pas le temps d'un mandat
présidentiel je parle qu'en 40 ans de
travail et sur l'ensemble des acteurs du
bâtiment pour rénover l'ensemble du parc
de logements et de bâtiments dans ce
pays
c'est donc des emplois locaux c'est dans
nos territoires ça mobilise les artisans
et les toutes petites entreprises
là vous créé d'emplois c'est pas
simplement en disant je vais donner deux
mille emplois ou faire baisser
d'echallens à propos de manière indécise
du plan de formation des chômeurs cinq
cent mille c'est certain dit c'est
impossible en une année enfin néanmoins
est-ce que
vous donner crédit à l'accusation qui
vise françois hollande on lui dit mais
en fait que vous cherchez non pas à
créer des emplois mais à escamoter les
statistiques en faisant basculer les
chômeurs dans la catégorie 2b
moi je vous dit rien c'est parce que
dans la tête de france hollande ce que
je peux vous dire c'est beaucoup de gens
chômage attendent d'avoir des réponses
positives de leurs demandes de formation
je suis élue régionale encore reçu hier
un courrier d'un francilien qui me
racontait qu'il avait postulé qu'il est
sur une formation qu'il est sur liste
d'attenté parce qu a pas assez de place
alors que c'est exactement la formation
qui l'attend donc il faut être quand
même très conscients qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de personnes au chômage
qualifié ou pas n'ont pas accès à ces
formations et c'est pour ça qu'on a
vraiment besoin maintenant d'ouvrir le
speg beaucoup plus largement
peut-être aussi de réformer le métier de
la formation de réformer tout cette
machine qui objectivement de fonction
alors le chef de l'état a également
esquissé hier semble-t-il une réforme
des allocations à qui sont versées aux
chômeurs que la cour des comptes
d'ailleurs dans la foulée à trouver
coûte son écoute françois hollande
je rappelle qu'en france la durée
d'indemnisation est la plus longue
d'europe mais la durée de formation des
chômeurs est la plus courte
c'est ce qu'il faut changer alors il
faut changer le système d'indemnisation
des chômeurs sur dix pour coûteux et
puis peut-être pas assez incitatif
ainsi la vie en général moi j'aimerais
bien que l'on parle du chômage est
notamment qu'on en parle qu'on y est et
moi j étais donc j'aimerais bien qu'un
moment tous les politiques au lieu de
lire des rapports et ses grandes phrases
comme la durée d'indemnisation la plus
longue d'europe regarde la réalité de ce
que ça veut dire tu ne pars aujourd'hui
la durée d'indemnisation peut-être en
théorie la plus longue que certains pays
d'europe mais pas tous et je vous
rappelle que d'autres pays les
organisations sont plus courtes mais il
ya aussi de la part de l'état un
meilleur service en termes d' aide à un
reclassement dead à la formation et des
aides à l'emploi et ensuite il faut
regarder la réaction du district escaut
d'où il faut réformer ou va dans le sens
évoqué par le chef de l'état et la cour
des comptes et jean marie le guen qui
était à votre place
la semaine dernière qui s'interrogeait
sur la dégressivité des aides
oui sur leur durée également alors vous
répondez quoi vous j'aime beaucoup les
états d'âme de
le mans terres qui sont en place depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années et qui n'ont
jamais connu la perte de l'emploi comme
monsieur le guen et je vais vous dire la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que quand de
parler du chômage on s'en prend aux
systèmes d'indemnisation en estimant
qu'il est trop coûteux et explose le
système il exposé pascal pas d'emploi le
système peut-être est-ce que c'est quoi
la solution c'est qu'on laisse les gens
à la rue c'est qu'on dise aux gens
demain vous n'avez pas la bonne
indemnisation la réalité c'est que
beaucoup de chômeurs qui ne touche pas
plus souvent de 56% 60% de leur salaire
antérieur net sont dans des grandes
difficultés financières se retrouvent en
difficulté y compris de payer des loyers
de nourrir leurs familles et beaucoup de
ces jeunes la demande d emploi
vous savez se termine une campagne
électorale
j'avais une équipe de campagne dont
l'ensemble de cette équipe est
aujourd'hui au chômage j'ai eu hier mon
ancien directeur de campagne qui m'a
raconté sa visite à pôle emploi avec une
question toute simple
crois tu vraiment qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
peut s'occuper de moi quand j'avais un
pôle emploi ce n'est pas le cas il n'y a
pas assez d'agents pour travailler
auprès des salariés diplômés ou pas il
n'y a pas assez d'argent que vous
travaillez auprès des jeunes et donc si
on veut vraiment réformer l'organisation
du chômage travaillons pour mettre plus
d'efforts sur le chômage et d'arrêter de
toujours vouloir pp sont les jambes on
ne touche pas on est tous pas et si on
ne touche pas et surtout s'implique sur
la vie des chemins il ya débat couac
administratif terrible il ya des zones
restaurées sur la réforme éventuelle
attaque en messieurs non c'est pas que
c'est intéressant c'est que j'en ai
assez dans ce pays et c'était déjà le
cas avec monsieur rebsamen qu'à chaque
fois qu'on parle du chômage c'est pour
taper sur les chômeurs une indemnisation
et ne jamais se poser la question de
savoir comment est ce qu'on à cette
période-là efficace y compris pour la
wii est utile vous êtes heurté
aujourd'hui ce pas d'unité de gauche
quand on vous entend c'est pas une
histoire d'unités moi j'ai des goûts
vous savez j'ai fait de la politique et
j'étais aussi dans le monde du travail
j'ai connu des licenciements j'ai connu
des dépôts de bilan je sais ce que c'est
je sais ce que c'est d'aller expliquer
sa vie un agent à pôle emploi qui ne
comprend rien de ce que vous faites
parce qu'il ne connaît pas votre métier
et qui vous dit est brouillée vous c'est
la réalité de beaucoup de gens donc
c'est très bien les formations je pense
que c'est très bien aussi si on n'a même
plus des aides aux salariés
c'est pôle emploi c'est d'état de
réseaux qui aujourd'hui mobilise les
les plus vieux les seniors les cadres
sur la question de l'emploi
mais arrêtons d'avoir cette recette
facile à droite comme à gauche qui est
de penser qu'il faut taper sur l'univers
à gauche un rôle a dit alors à gauche
c'est bien françois hollande c'est jean
marie le guen on sait que c'est aussi
une idée partagée par manuel valls
il vous met en pétard mais sait pas qui
met en pétard je pense que c'est pas la
solution et que c'est pas en rognant sur
des indemnités qui sont pas énormes dans
ce pays et qu'on va répondre
la cour des comptes appelle calcule
ainsi en rogne
comme vous l'êtes effectivement parce
que ça revient on allège le fardeau de
la grêle de la cour des comptes fasse
aussi le calcul après de ce que veut
dire de mettre plus de gens dans la
pauvreté et comme ils vont coûter à
l'état
combien coûterait les impayés augmenter
le loyer parce que des gens n'ont plus
leurs indemnités chômage
combien ça coûterait que des gens ne
payent plus leur pension alimentaire ne
payent plus leurs impôts etc etc
le chômage il a un coût c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se battre contre le chômage
et pas contre les chômeurs alors à
l'occasion de la présentation de ce plan
emploi on a senti que emmanuel macron
est un peu marginalisé actuellement je
ne sais pas si vous le ressentez
également plutôt au profit de la
ministre du travail
est-ce que cela vous satisfait comme
schéma écoutez franchement j'ai pas de
point de vue sur le sujet que la milice
du travail s'occupe des questions
d'emploi me semble à peu près évident et
au ministre de l'économie avait fait des
propositions avaient été reconnus
sangloter petit salé jeudi soir dans ce
cousin de moi je manque encore
objectivement je n'ai pas à juger de
cela parce que françois hollande va
perdre lamentablement son pari sur
l'emploi d'ici 2017 selon vous je pense
qu'en tout cas à miser tout 100 mag à
son engagement sur glace de la version
d'une courbe du chômage
quant à côté on change rien du mode de
développement économique de ce pays
c'est un pari extrêmement risqué après
vous savez moi je ne lis pas dans
l'avenir et je n'en sais rien alors on
espère en tous les cas que le chômage va
effectivement reculé indices et surtout
après je vais vous dire c'est surtout
que pour c'est important pour les gens
qui sont en difficulté la plus honnête
l'avenir politique des uns et des autres
absolument alors la question se pose est
ce que françois hollande s'est piégé
avec son pari justement sur une
inversion de la courbe alors qu'il ya eu
quand même six cent cinquante mille
chômeurs de plus depuis 2012
emmanuelle cosse et ce qu'il sait piégé
avec son pari comme il s'est piégé
semble-t-il avec la déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes vous
poser de questions différents le fait
qu'il est vous
par cette phrase sur l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage tout cas c'est comme
ça que j'avais compris à l'époque dire
que c'était sa mobilisation
tu as fait son droit et moi j'ai aucun
problème avec toute personnelle et
politique cherche à mettre son d'emplois
au premier rang mais dans l'accord est
donné sur la d chanson est tirée de la
déchéance de nationalité je sais pas si
c'est un piège mais c'est surtout le
fait que c'est un piège pour aujourd'hui
pourquoi il a voulu peut-être je ne sais
pas sandra que j'ai à la droite et la
gauche
vous savez moi je suis très premier
degré dans la vie je suis pas dans la
posture je pense qu'un moment quoi on
fait des choix politiques faut les
assumer jusqu'au bout
le présent de la république a fait le
choix de présenter cette mesure qui est
pour moi un non sens et une
incompréhension totale et ce qui est
certain c'est que le 23 décembre quand
ça a été annoncé on nous a expliqué
qu'en gros les quelques personnes comme
moi et d'autres qui est ce 18 contre
nous nous égarons si je me souviens bien
à l'expression du premier ministre
la réalité c'est que cette proposition
fait du mal elle fait du mal dans la
société que le débat politique continue
perdure et que j'espère surtout que je
présente un public d'avoir la
clairvoyance de vous cette position mais
il va pas enlever la déchéance de
nationalité les pros il a prononcé la
formule devant le congrès il a souhaité
rencontrer des groupes parlementaires et
partis politiques vendredi donc je ne
sais pas pour quelle caisse qui voudra
nous dire maintenant on cherche une
solution une solution cémenté je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de solution
le skateur livre le plus terrible avec
la déchéance de nationalité c'est de
vous expliquer que la nationalité c'est
ce qui va nous différencier et c'est ça
le problème quand vous dites que la
république est une et indivisible
la construction de notre état s'est fait
sur des grands principes et c'est ce qui
fait tout sommes un grand pays et c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est une
erreur d'avoir été là bas là dedans
maintenant des expressions ont été
émises depuis décembre pour trouver une
porte de sortie différente indignité
nationale par exemple ou d'autres sujets
en tout cas les portes ont été fermées
par le gouvernement à chaque fois ce qui
est certain c est qu il ya eu la fameuse
formule prononcée devant le congrès à
des changements
l'intelligence est de savoir reconnaître
quand on a pu faire une erreur ou
coûtant veut évoluer est ce que vraiment
aujourd'hui demander à francis que
vraiment aujourd'hui la mémoire connais
ton erreur et évolue en tout cas je
pense sincèrement que les français ont
besoin d'un état fort ont besoin d'un
d'une unité ont besoin d'action et je ne
crois pas qu'aujourd'hui il est besoin
de déchéance de nationalité aux besoins
de survenu autour des valeurs communes
et d'un destin partagé habituellement
écouter écouter écouter ce que dit à ce
sujet
manuel valls qui lui défend cette mesure
symbolique de la défense mais
nationalité regardez vous réagissez être
français ça n'est pas seulement la
nationalité la nationalité c'est un
droit juridique mais la nationalité
d'une certaine manière on doit la gagner
c'est l'appartenance je vous le disais
tout à l'heure à une communauté de
valeurs c'est quoi être français c'est
pas un papier seulement
c'est l'appartenance à des valeurs
liberté égalité fraternité laïcité c'est
ce que nous sommes et c'est construire
ça égaye permanente
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
le premier ministre n'est pas seulement
français avec un morceau de pop la
nationale i plus que ça en été n'est pas
un morceau de papier est avant tout une
inscription dans un pays sa construction
et ses valeurs et moi je veux qu'on ait
un véritable débat qui est que des
français qu'ils étaient binationaux ou
pas ont décidé de s'attaquer à leur pays
c'est ça que je veux combattre doivent
être exclues de la communauté nationale
faisait battre par des peines par
décembre sur sa venue sur les mesures
symboliques mesure symbole et quoi que
ce soit mais ça n'a rien à voir la
nationalité est ce que vous croyez que
si les gens de citoyenneté à une
indignité noces en tout cas en tout cas
décidé de poser le débat sur la question
de la nationalité
ces remèdes dans notre société une
division sur ce qui fait aujourd'hui
qu'on se reconnaît ou pas français et
par ailleurs quoi qu'en disent les uns
et les autres j'ai encore dû encore
entendu ce matin stéphane le foll qui
rappelait sur un autre média qui ne
s'agissait que des crimes terroristes
mais il n'empêche que depuis qu'ils ont
fait cette proposition
on n'entend que des bi nationaux de tous
bords binationaux de tapei qui nous
disent comment ils se sentent meurtri
parce que viser et c'est ça qu'il faut
moment comprendre c'est que sa douce à
certains adhèrent même s'ils sont
binationaux en ligne
tandis qu'on prie je peux vous dire dans
ma vie quotidienne je suis arrêté par
des gens qui ne me parle que de ça parce
qu'ils sont choqués ils sont choqués je
vis dans un quartier qui n'est pourtant
pas très populaire de paris et pourtant
c'est le cas et un moment il faut avoir
cette reconnaissance là agissons contre
le terrorisme agissons continent qui
nous attaque
mais excusez moi quand on dit y compris
dans ses premiers skis l'a dit cette
mesure n'a pas d'efficacité elle n'est
que symbolique
alors pourquoi vous l'avez rappelé vous
même mais sa forme est le symbole il est
important pour nous unir et le problème
c'est qu'en utilisant cette mesure là
qui par le passé par le passé a été
utilisée par des pompes à faire le
parallèle historique avec mes soir à
vichy et vichy et vichy et c'est pas
vichy lisez hannah arendt lisait comment
l'allemagne et d'autres pays ont décidé
d'exclure des juifs de leur pays de
leurs communautés en passant par la
déchéance de nationalité
rappelons nous rappelons nous le combat
de rené cassin contre les apatrides et
moi je suis désolé je suis juriste de
formation c'est un débat et mines ont
aujourd'hui la déchéance de nationalité
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi on a fait
l'europe pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
pourquoi est ce que de gaulle dans les
années 50 et en 58 décide d'aller plus
loin sur le sujet des droits
fondamentaux
c'est extrêmement grave et aujourd'hui
le terrorisme ne doit pas nous conduire
à oublier ce qui a fait votre grandeur
nos valeurs et ce qui fait à l'aise
france au volant que vous aurez
peut-être entendu manuel valls se
déclare aujourd'hui à une télé suisse
nous ne pouvons pas dire aux réfugiés
venez et encore moins venez tous il a
raison non non mais ça c'est si vous
voulez ce problème est absolument
navrant et jalonnant les problèmes
redoutable que ça pose à notre société
dit il qu'on peut pas leur dire venez
tous excusez moi mais aujourd'hui il y a
pas un premier problème il ya des
réfugiés en europe
ils sont sur les routes d'europe ils
sont un certain nombre sont arrivés en
allemagne sont aussi en france je ne
crois pas qu'on peut simplement dire aux
réfugiés ne venez pas ce sont des gens
qui quittent la guerre l'exil les
violences la détresse et la mort et de
toute façon rien n'arrêtera leur chemin
donc la question maintenant et c'est pas
une paye une réponse française
la question est de savoir si l'europe
est capable de répondre dignement à cela
et d'avoir une politique européenne
d'accueil tout simplement et ça peut
aussi un peu la suisse qui n'est pas
dans l'europe mais qui a certainement
des choses à faire sur ce
jean d'ormesson votre soir les yeux dans
les yeux avec le premier ministre lui a
dit vous vous êtes droitiser manuel
valls il avait raison jean d'ormesson
je me rappelle du candidat à la primaire
de 2011 qui sortent un certain sujet est
à peu près le même que premier ministre
aujourd'hui donc moi est ce que je crois
surtout c'est que il ya une volonté
d'avoir un discours d'autorité je suis
pas sûr que c'est comme ça que l'on peut
faire de l'adhésion autour de soi aller
deuxième partie de preuves par 3 avec
cette question faut-il une primaire de
la gauche pour un seul candidat en 2017
missiles malandain de la fpf va vous
poser la question pour manuel valls
toujours lui françois hollande est le
candidat naturel de la gauche mais le
temps a quand même évolué on l'a noté
ces derniers jours chez certains
socialistes écoutent ont par exemple
julien dray proche du chef de l'état
si la primaire elle sert à régler des
comptes ou alignés les uns ou les autres
à faire jurer un tribunal dans lequel
devrait passer tel ou tel candidat
dans quel intérêt si la primaire par
contre elle sert avoir un vrai débat et
à choisir celui qui le mieux ou le plus
en capacité de représenter la gauche
toute la gauche
alors elle est utile donc la question
qui est posée elle est simple oui à une
primaire de toute la gauche en vue
d'avoir un seul candidat à ce que la
question qui est sous jacente à tout
cela c'est d'être présent au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle de ne
pas recommencer le 21 avril 2002 on ne
pas faire une campagne électorale de
prix de premier tour on sait pas où on
va
donc il faut évidemment se rassembler
pour se rassembler il faut être capable
de trouver la solution à la lucide mais
on aimerait rejoindre soir ça concerne
votre question
emmanuelle cosse donc sur cette primaire
alors quelle est votre position sur sur
une primaire de la gauche est ce que
c'est une bonne idée ce que les
conditions sont réunies
alors tout d'abord cet appel pour une
primaire moi je pense qu'il a été
salvateur parce qu'en fait il a ouvert
un débat que tout le monde croyait déjà
clos on a démarré l'année politique 2016
en nous expliquant toutes façons les
candidats étaient déjà décidée pour 2010
est que les choses étaient joués et que
ça serait en train tel et un tel et
qu'on faisait quasiment 2012 ce débat il
est importante parce qu'il n'est pas
porté que par des politiques
essentiellement par des personnalités
qui sont hors des partis politiques et
qui ont beaucoup d'écologistes 1 il ya
quelques écologistes
il ya en effet yannick jadot député
européen elle cohn bendit
éminent écologistes qui sont à l'origine
de ce texte mais quelque chose qui s'est
fait totalement en dehors de notre parti
est compris nous n'étions pas du tout
dans la boucle de cette proposition mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est ce disent
ayant le débat et la primaire c'est pas
simplement à la fin de savoir quel
candidat va y aller il ya aussi derrière
leurs propositions un processus moi que
je trouve très important qui est d'avoir
des mobilisations des échanges mais
alors juste essayé de construire de
construire qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
que demain nous ayons un projet qui va
au delà même des candidats et qui
permettent de répondre aussi à une
question pour 2010 est qui et comment
est ce combat-là commentateur de la nasa
une primaire de la gauche envisagent des
contributions des débats publics était
de créer une plateforme de
programmatique
mais comment est-ce possible à l'heure
actuelle en france dans le monde
politique de gauche qu'on puisse avoir
ce débat sans que des candidats émergent
et commence à avoir des positions
tout d'abord tout d'abord moi j'ai pas
pourquoi on pourrait pas changer
processus par rapport à l'élection
présidentielle et y compris le
moderniser la droite va enfin faire une
primaire c'est quand même assez inédit
je ne sais pas comment ils en sortiront
mais c'est le cas là le ps avait fait
une gauche une primaire ouverte à la
gauche en 2011 qui a quand même permis
de construire derrière une candidature à
la présidentielle qui l'a emporté et je
ne vois pas pourquoi dans notre pays à
l'avenir on pourrait pas avoir des
primaires à chaque fois objectivement
aujourd'hui et vous l'avez noté
on a eu une position de jeunes très
forte de jean christophe cambadélis le
premier jour de cet appel une certaine
ouverture
je ne sais pas ce que fera à la fin
françois hollande s'il se déclare
candidat à quoi que ce soit je n'en sais
rien en tout cas je ne vois pas pourquoi
on ne pourrait pas posé la question tous
les cinq ans de savoir est ce qu'on doit
pas avoir une évolution sur le sujet là
qu'est ce que vous dites par exemple
vous êtes adressé tout à l'heure à
françois hollande d'une certaine manière
sur la déchéance de nationalité
qu'est ce que vous lui dites aujourd'hui
par exemple à françois hollande qui
redoute on l'a entendu un dans la bouche
de julien dray
c'est devant un tribunal passer devant
les plis finale vous savez alors oui
comme garantie que j'ai déjà je ne suis
pas à l'initiative de 7 à vous la
défendent et je la défends alors je ne
suis pas tout à l'initiative mais j'ai
lu et je vais rencontrer d'ailleurs
leurs auteurs à leur demande en tant que
chef de parti je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
ya deux ans je un ne pas simplement
baisser les bras avant la présidentielle
et se dire que la seule question est de
savoir qu'est ce qu'on va voter face à
marine le pen
moi je me refuse à ce que le débat
présidentiel soit celui là puisque c'est
celui là qui s'imposent à nous
aujourd'hui par rapport à des sondages
et pour ça ça veut dire quoi qu'il
arrive primaire ou pas primaire qu'il
faut qu'il y ait du débat politique de
la confrontation de la modernisation
parce que c'est pas simplement de faire
de la contribution non la bourrine
arrivé aussi là qu'il faut aussi qu'on
soit capable aujourd'hui d'utiliser le
temps politique du débat avant une
présidentielle pour se poser des
questions sur ces quads avec des
réponses aux enjeux du monde en 2016 en
2020 2030
jean luc mélenchon qui est crédité d'une
dizaine de pourcents dans les sondages
actuels sur la présidentielle de 2017 a
déjà fermé la porte à cette primaire
mais c'est bien son problème
moi je pense qu'on ne peut plus faire
comme avant je ne pense qu'on ne peut
plus faire comme avant
je ne sais pas combien il sera à la fin
et s'il sera candidat mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui personne n'a la science
infuse et personne ne peut dire je serai
au second tour de la présidentielle ou
même je serai au premier tour et donc
tout ce qui peut permettre aujourd'hui
de redynamiser ce débat politique de
faire des propositions de ne pas arriver
désarmé devant les électeurs ce qu'on a
pu voir parfois chez certains candidats
me semble important d'autant plus moi je
veux bien qu'on se raconte n'importe
quoi sur la montée du front national
mais cette montée elle est aussi
possible parce que les gens ont décidé
de se mettre en retrait du vote est en
retrait de l'actualité politique
il ne voit plus depuis 2012 pas
simplement des gens à gauche beaucoup à
gauche un peu à droite
il faut s'interroger sur pourquoi des
gens décident que le temps politique
dans notre pays qui est si politisé ne
les intéresse plus et donc la primaire
peut être un élément pour faire cela
après faut seulement posé des conditions
se pensent qu'elle ne sera réussi que
s'il ya beaucoup de candidats et que
j'espère il y aura les principaux élus
les autres quittent la ligne
et en tout cas à 10 je le crois ce que
veulent faire les organisateurs mais
encore une fois ils ont lancé un premier
appel ils veulent lancer l'initiative
ils ont demandé à rencontrer des
représentants de partis politiques pour
échanger avec eux donc on en est dans
une phase une première phase mais moi je
trouve intéressant que dans ce temps
démocratique qui semblait arrêter ou y
compris vous vous journalistes vous nous
expliquer qu'en fait tout était joué et
qu'on se quasiment on se revoit en avril
2017 se trouve intéressant d'avoir un
autre débat sur notre forme il semble
que il semble que des candidats
écologistes se prépare à une éventuelle
candidature en 2017
ça se dit ça se sait
est ce que ça veut dire que si jamais
cette primaire n'a pas lieu
je suppose c'est un lait ce que vous
venez de nous dire le il pourrait y
avoir un candidat écologiste qui se
présenterait donc face à françois
hollande face à jean luc mélenchon
en tout cas c'est c'est un débat que le
parti au lendemain des élections
régionales n'avaient pas encore ouvert
mais vous le savez on a un congrès dans
la fin du sommet cela en juin et pour
moi ça sera un débat qui aura lieu à ce
moment là avant le congrès où
certainement juste après en tout cas ça
fait partie des échéances pour n'importe
quel parti politique de s'interroger sur
ces choix là y compris comme comme comme
notre parti et voyez vous comme candidat
je vais pas vous demander de trancher
mais non mais déjà très clairement et je
les dis au delà même pas c'est parce que
le problème c'est pas qu'une histoire de
candidature de partie il faut
aujourd'hui être capable d'avoir des
candidats qui sont capables de parler à
la société toute entière
et moi j'ai dit je pense qu'elle que
trois personnes c'est qu'ils portent
l'écologie de manière extrêmement large
et cécile duflot c'est nicolas hulot et
c'est daniel cohn bendit ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont candidats qu'ils sont
partants je vous dis à mes yeux les gens
qui aujourd'hui ont cette capacité à
aller avoir un projet politique qui
embrase largement la famille politique
mais qui va bien au delà
mais alors il n'y a pas un risque dans
ces cas-là de dispersion comme on sait
maintenant quasiment un coup sûr comme
un livre épais nova sera présente au
deuxième tour est-ce que s'il ya un
candidat mais vous voyez c'est ça que
c'est à dire qu'on décide sur le
fondement des derniers résultats aux
élections régionales et de sondages que
à qoussaya marine le pen qui sera là qui
peut vraiment prédire le temps politique
franchement qui peut dire un an et demi
avant l'armée au mieux conjurer le
danger vient me voir
excusez-moi déjà la première chose que
je pense qu'il faut la combattre et
aujourd'hui vous le voyez bien elle est
très absente des médias
on n'entend rien de ce que pensent les
élus régionaux et on les voit très en
retrait on les voit en train de préparer
la prochaine offensive qui est la
présidentielle je pense qu'il faut les
combattre et y compris combattre dans
les terreaux ils ont gagné vous avez vu
la fiche qu'elle a préparé je ne sais
pas à quelle élection il a dessiné je ne
sais pas si c'est pour la présidentielle
on l'a vu en tous les cas photographier
dans son bureau avec derrière elle la
fiche et qu'elle en vedette avec le
slogan la france apaisée et oui mais
marine le pen sait utiliser la
communication comme d'autres et reprend
des slogans je pense que vous pourrez
avoir sont beaucoup de personnalités
politiques de droite comme de gauche
d'ailleurs
ce qui est certain c'est que chez les
français il ya un besoin d'apaisement et
de répondre à leurs difficultés mais
c'est aussi pour ça que quand je dis la
combattre c'est aussi combattre qui fait
le terreau du front national c'est à
dire de remettre des services publics là
où ça va très fortement le front
national de répondre au sentiment
d'abandon donc qu'il ya réellement dans
beaucoup de régions et qu'on réponde
aussi à la peur de l'avenir
quand vous voyez dans certaines régions
il ya des votes à plus de 50% dans
certaines communes pour marine le pen on
doit s'interroger aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui fait que des gens se portent aussi
majoritairement faire elle alors vous
avez reconnu c'était l'heure de vous
veut un manuel cause que vous êtes
trompés aux régionales vous avez déclaré
que vous ne vouliez plus d'alliance avec
la gauche radicale
alors finalement est-ce que vous donner
raison aux dissidents françois de rugy
qui était récemment sur le plateau de
public sénat en l'écoutent duflot par
exemple qui n'ont cessé de dire mais
nous allons incarner l'alternative au
parti socialiste les électeurs non
regardez ce que ça a donné
casser la gueule 8% en
nord-pas-de-calais picardie 6 5% en
provence alpes côte d'azur c'est un
échec total et il porte aussi une
responsabilité dans le fait que la
gauche et les écologistes ne soit plus
représenté dans ces régions déjà je vais
vous dire je ne devrais pas raison à
françois de rugy parce que je pense que
s'il avait des désaccords il fallait
qu'il est qu'ils les portent et qui les
défendent au sein de son parti et ce
qu'il a fait avec d'autres de partir
d'heures partie qui les a fait lire qui
les a portés pendant tant d'années à
quatre mois d'une élection quelque chose
d'absolument inacceptable et
inacceptables y compris en termes de
loyauté il était il était opposé et moi
j'ai dit il comprime la manière que
j'aurais fait autrement dans cette
région il est opposé au choix coiffer la
région nord pas de calais de présenter
une liste autonome l'avait dit il avait
dit mais ça dans ce cas là il fallait
aussi défendre cette idée jusqu'au bout
défendre d'émotion aller chercher des
votes et pas de faire ce qui a été fait
qui est à dire de quitter un parti qui
était sa famille politique pour la
dézinguer la dessoudé et en même temps à
faiblir tout le monde y compris je le
redis les régions décident dans notre
partie de leur choix aux stratégies
leurs choix stratégiques aux élections
sur douze régions nous avions huit
régions d'assaut avions des listes
écologistes
je dis bien des listes écologistes
certaines régions ont fait le choix de
s'allier avec partie on va pas refaire
c'est dans ces régions que les résultats
ont été faibles donc c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai donc objectivement qu'il y a eu
en effet des erreurs mais vous savez ici
la réalité d'organisation de mon parti
si on est si on est dans une dans une
préparation de primaires si on est dans
l'idée d'un compromis et que vous ne
voulez plus aller du côté du front de
gauche
alors vous allez peut-être vous tourner
du côté du ps et non mais vous voyez ils
ont même un plan de poser la question a
vraiment très bien la faille et je
l'avais pas poser sa question
écologistes je suis désolé de le redire
c'est pour ça que ce parti s'est créé
c'est pour ça que ce parti s'est créée
il ya 30 ans et je pense qu'il compris
dans mon parti
quand on veut réduire le débat en gros
entre françois de logique qu'il y aille
avec le ps ou d'autres qui disent aller
avec mélenchon ça n'a pas de sens si
nous avons un moment décider y compris
moi j'ai décidé la première fois que
j'ai été dans un parti politique c'est
pour aller dans un parti écologiste
c'est bien parce que je trouvais ma
réponse ni dans la social démocratie ni
dans le communisme et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui les écologistes ont une
seule à mon avis obligation pour pas se
planter comme ça a été le cas aux
dernières élections
c'est de faire de l'écologie et de
répondre à ce pourquoi nous sommes
appréciés
parce que nous apportons de l'écologie
dans ses politiques parce que sony eut
malgré tout il y aurait pas eu la coop
22 vous dis entrante dans le
gouvernement oui à l'occasion d'un
remaniement au niveau des pêches oui est
ce que est ce que vous avez été approché
est-ce que vous réfléchissez est ce que
vous savez déjà que vous y allez où vous
n'y allez pas je je je peux vous dire en
tout cas on aime ce que je lis dans la
presse y compris dans vos dépêche ne
vient ni de moi et non je n'ai pas des
rendez-vous à l'elysée pour décider de
mon avenir ministériel
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir comment
cette cette sauce la montre quand on a
un débat politique essentiel que sur la
déchéance de nationalité et que tout le
monde veut essayer de l'enterrer ce
débat là ne va pas être enterré on peut
trouver des subterfuges
il ya eu le plan poids il ya ces rumeurs
de remaniement tout le monde ce qui
s'excitent hausse alors que c'est une
fausse rumeur que ça veut dire son
élément
je ne suis pas ce n'est pas le sujet et
par messure vous proposer d'entrée donc
également aujourd'hui que diriez vous je
dirais je pense que je vous ai déjà
répondu à plusieurs reprises pour quoi
faire pour cacher la question serez vous
demande qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire dans la douleur la fin
de mandature
quels sont les projets de ce
gouvernement est ce que vraiment vous
voulez faire une politique très écolo
qui répond notamment aux besoins de
création d'emplois est ce que l'on fait
de notre dame des landes est ce que l'on
ce que l'on arrête votre dame des landes
est ce que l'on ferme sessenheim ayons
les vrais débats y pourriez les débats
mais vous sectorielle dialogue le
derrière par exemple comme cécile duflot
il n'en est pas question avec manuel
valls premier ministre mais ça n'a
jamais été la position que j'ai tenus de
l'international j'ai toujours voulu
avoir une discussion politique et un
moment il faut arrêter entre les rumeurs
sur des remaniements et le fait que à
chaque fois il n'y a pas de discussion
politique qui fait dire que ce mandat
n'est pas n'est pas terminée tout est
encore possible
les écologistes peuvent encore entraînez
vous savez moi j'ai souvenir de la fin
du mandat du gouvernement fillon
j'étais alors vice-présidente de la
région j'ai négocié avec certains
ministres
à deux jours de l'élection
présidentielle des choses concernant des
questions de logements d'habitat
insalubre il concerne notamment une
ville de seine-saint-denis et ça
concerne quinze mille personnes donc je
vais vous dire la politique elle
s'arrête jusqu'au moment où vous n'êtes
plus en poste quand j'étais présidente
d'act up
il ya fort longtemps je me rappelle
avoir négocié des choses dans
l'entre-deux tours des législatives donc
il faut arrêter de penser qu'à un moment
les choses s'arrêtent en politique ce
n'est pas vrai à l'irlande jour possible
et y compris françois hollande même s'il
perdait l'élection il serait malgré tout
en fonction jusqu'à toi et il a des
pouvoirs d'action et là dessus je pense
que c'est très important d'arrêter de
laisser penser que le temps politique
s'arrête whisky va s'arrêter ça moment
là la discussion législative
sauf que vous avez des élus vous avez
des minutes vous avez des tas de
personnes qui sont en responsabilité
jusqu'au bout leur mandat et qu'on des
moyens d'action mais alors soyez prêtes
à un foyer de presles parce que on en
annonce un remaniement imminent alors
vous avez discuté je suis surtout prête
pour porter des sujets écolo pour battre
à la région quand la nouvelle majorité
de droite mais porter des sujets ou non
au gouvernement alors justement vous
voulez pas nous répondre sur le
gouvernement est ce que
est-ce que les autres questions sur
votre avenir est ce que vous allez vous
représenter à la tête d'europe écologie
les verts lors du congrès au mois de
juin eh bien c'est la même manière et en
plus c'est pas aux prises puisque nous
en avions discuté ensemble lors de notre
dernier conseil fédéral on est
aujourd'hui donc on a clôturé cette
question là maintenant on est tous en
train de travailler sur le prochain
congrès sur quelle base on fait comment
avec qui et comme j'avais dis je c'est
là dessus que je travaille aujourd'hui
avant de décider si oui ou non je me
représente
alors chaque chose en son temps je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'ampli normes y compris
chez les écologistes on a besoin aussi
de nous ne se poser ça fait cinq
élections qu'on enchaîne on a besoin
aussi de reconstruire les bases de notre
projet et notamment de notre capacité à
aller à l'encontre dès électeurs pour
2010 merci les faits maintenant dans une
petite question tiens à propos de ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale est ce une bonne idée pour une
députée écologiste faire appel à pamela
anderson pour dénoncer le gavage au nom
les producteurs de foie vent le sait
sont victimes de la crise de la grippe
aviaire on a entendu des députés furieux
dont un socialiste par exemple qui a
dénoncé cette politique spectacle avec
cette vieille gloire des sites comme je
pense que les députés dénoncer la
politique spectacle quand je vois leur
spectacle aux questions au gouvernement
je propose que chacun reste calme notre
député laurent sabeg veut défendre la
cause animale et donc être assez
proposer enfin à proposer une
proposition de loi sur l'interdiction du
gavage des oies
moi je pense que c'est pas le sujet
essentiel du moment ces producteurs sont
en très grande difficulté ça fait débat
au sein d'un groupe écologiste
ça fait des boks à nos groupes
écologistes et que surtout il faut qu'on
mette fin aux élevages industriels qui
aujourd'hui amène aussi simple grippe
aviaire et touche en premier lieu des
agriculteurs et des éleveurs qui sont
eux dans des manières de faire un peu
différente
après pamela anderson ou n'importe qui
d'autre je pense que toutes les
personnes qui de bonne foi sont engagés
pour la cause animale elles doivent le
respect est ce que j'ai entendu sur elle
avec des propos ultra machiste et
misogyne franchement ça ne glorifie
personne et comme par hasard à chaque
fois c'est de la part des députés mal
et malheureusement en tout cas depuis
2012 c'est pas la première fois qu'on a
ces remarques la ou des attitudes je
vous rappellerai les les comme on dit
commenter les commentaires sur la robe
de ces quolibets les députés qui font la
poule quand véronique masson nous parle
donc sincèrement je pense qu'il ya un
moment où les députés doit surtout se
poser des questions sur la question de
la misogynie avant toute chose encore
troisièmes parties de préparer avec
michaël szames et ce qui arrive nous
allons donc aborder plusieurs dossiers
environnementaux vous voulez les portes
et vous l'avais dit il ya un instant
alors on va d'abord à évoquer les
moteurs diesel qui polluent plus que
nous le disent les tests dr renaud l'a
bien reconnu aujourd'hui alors peut-on
faire confiance aux constructeurs c'est
la question que vous posez un mickaël
dans un instant et comptant d'abord sur
le sujet ségolène royal il dirigeants de
ces entreprises ont accepté aussi de
venir s'expliquer devant la commission
ce qui est important c'est que la
pollution de l'air s'arrête et que le
constructeur automobile très prennent
acte de cacher ce qu'on leur dit pour
qu'il puisse régler les moteurs est ce
que va faire d'ailleurs renault pour
régler correctement à moteur il faut une
demi journée et donc renault s'est
engagé à faire en sorte à rappeler un
certain nombre de véhicules plus de
quinze mille véhicules pour les les
vérifier et pour les régler correctement
pour que le système de filtration
fonctionne même quand il fait très chaud
quand il fait en dessous 17° parce que
c'est là que les systèmes de filtration
ne marchait plus bonsoir michael
question très simple
renault reconnaît une erreur faute
avouée à moitié pardonnée
non non non je crois que ce qui se passe
c'est extrêmement grave et au moins on
peut se féliciter que y ait cette
commission mise en place très rapidement
presque un album vague où on a obtenu
que tout de suite soit tester des
véhicules français parce qu'au départ ce
n'était pas vraiment le cas
et la réalité en tout cas les
informations que moi j'ai pu obtenir
c'est que semble-t-il iliad et donc des
défaillances sur les véhicules renault
sont des systèmes de dépollution qui ne
fonctionne pas à la ministre vient de le
dire ça ne fonctionne pas en dessous de
17 degrés et obligation renault et
d'autres constructeurs et dans les
dribbles en effet que j'ai lu il ya
y compris d'autres constructeurs qu'on
nous dit étrangers mais attention dans
mon souvenir n'a été testé que 22 ou 25
véhicules sur une centaine est ce qu'ils
vont tous montés en tout cas ce qui se
raconte
cki compris dans les tests qui sont
faits à l'étranger dans d'autres pays où
les mêmes commissions ont été mises en
place c'est qu'on retrouve les mêmes
défaillances chez plusieurs
constructeurs et que semble-t-il ce qui
a été dit aux consommateurs qu'ils
achètent leurs voitures sur le respect
de ce nombre de normes et tout ça son
faux qui a peut-être tromperie donc
c'est extrêmement grave qu en train de
se passer et je voudrais pourquoi je
trouve ça grave je trouve ça grave parce
qu'on trompe le consommateur et y
compris on trompe les autorités sur la
question de la pollution mais ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est aujourd'hui de
l'avenir des entreprises
on a des salariés arnaud qu un
savoir-faire renault est une grande
maison où l'état est en plus actionnaire
qui produit des véhicules de qualité
mais qui en train en fait de nous dire
que sur sa toute sa production diesel il
ya une erreur donc la question que je
pose est ce que renault là demain se
modernise et montre qu'en fait il n'y a
pas de véhicules diesel qui peuvent être
propre parce que moi ce que je veux
qu'on sauve c'est les emplois de renault
et donc c'est un enjeu majeur parce que
vous avez vu l'effondrement de la bourse
la semaine dernière et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'on a l'impression
chrono n'est pas si inquiet du sujet l
on connaît une erreur de calibrage sur
un modèle et rappelle quinze mille
véhicules au kerry ont réagi sauf que je
crois que le problème va être beaucoup
plus importants qu'en savons les normes
on sait qu'on nous dit pas au départ
c'est pour ça que je voulais quelque
chose de caché c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que moi j'attends de voir les 100
véhicules testés
parce que là on nous parle d'un vécu et
notamment les plus récents qu'en est il
des plus anciens pourquoi est-ce que
lier un problème est qu'on l'a pas vu
avant
est-ce que excusez moi de poser des
questions aussi triviale mais on
découvre seul à l'occasion de ces tests
est ce que donc renault savez où est ce
que c'est une erreur
tout le monde s'est trompé est ce que
vraiment dans la chaîne de direction il
n'y a pas de sujet pourquoi est ce que
c'est si grave
renault en même temps contrairement à
peugeot a quand même réussi à rattraper
son retard sur les véhicules électriques
est en train de développer notamment un
véhicule qui marche plutôt bien il ya un
enjeu majeur parce que c'est parts de
marché là aujourd'hui en france en
europe sont prises par des constructeurs
étrangers notamment asiatiques et donc
la question de savoir aussi c'est quoi
le modèle
mobile pour l'europe si on parle un
petit peu de consommateurs comme vous
l'avez fait actuellement août dernier
kouao français aujourd'hui on se
rappelle qu'au moment de volkswagen ya
eu des actions groupe très importantes
qui ont été menées il faudra même chose
en france faudra faire pareil déjà
s'envole zagat ne sait pas si elles ont
eu lieu en tout cas moi je me rappelle
qu'il fait des déclarations d'intention
pour par des actions groupe
il faudra en faire aussi sur renault
imaginez quand même que des personnes
s'endettent pour acheter un véhicule qui
est nécessaire souvent pour aller
travailler pour être mobile on leur dit
qu'en gros on leur a menti mais qu'en
plus ils vont pas pouvoir le vendre
le prix qu'ils ont acheté ou qui peuvent
en espérer c'est le cas pour les gens
qui ont des oiseaux aux aguets les décès
at et tout ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui
pourquoi il ya des actions parce qu'ils
ne peuvent rien faire de leur véhicule
pire que ça je suis sur des personnes
ont été ses véhicules en pensant agir
correctement pour la planète en étant
vraiment citoyens de ce point de vue là
ont cru qu'on ait un tel véhicule
il allait avoir à faire un effort
peut-être payer plus cher ils ont été
dupés mais sur des choses en plus qui
sont des gens qui veulent changer leur
comportement donc un moment il faut
arrêter de salir et réparation vous
dites dans des avions de gros contre un
constructeur en série transparence donc
à qui regroupe les wii et un peu s'est
excusé moi à l'état français et l'état
est actionnaire de peugeot on a augment
de renault pardo et de plus on a
augmenté notre part chez renault l'état
est donc stratège dans ce conseil
d'administration s'est abîmé fait peur
est ce que l'état est au courant de cela
en tant que membre du conseil
d'administration depuis quand à qui ces
informations là semble-t-il personne ne
l'avait en tout cas à l'environnement
est ce que bercy les avais et que fait
l'état demain que fait l'état
l'administration taureau de renault je
ne dis pas ça je dis que quand on est
stratège quand on est un état stratège
dans des entreprises dans lesquelles on
a des participations
on peut pas simplement dire c'est un peu
grâce à renault il ya peugeot il ya
l'avenir de ces emplois et l'autre
choses sur lesquelles je ne voudrais pas
qu'on oublie quand même le premier sujet
qui est que tout cela part de la
question du diesel
le choix fait par la france de
développer ce type de motorisation qui
est nocif pour notre santé qui coûtent
des milliards etc des rapports un
rapport sénatorial qui le montrent qu'
aujourd'hui un impact sur la santé
publique
et moi je souhaite qu'on sauvegarde est
sympa de l'automobile donc comment on
fait pour qu'à voir la transparence et
ne pas répéter à l'avenir ces mêmes
erreurs justement comment
du pétrole et une forcément du diesel je
termine avec ce point nous commission
denquête c'est quelque chose que vous
pourriez demander de la part des élus
verts par exemple
en tout cas je sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est
en réflexion paris en tout cas il ya
cette première il ya cette commission là
mais je pense qu'il faut tout le monde
veut déjà l'eau propre à la fin du
processus et donc commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
en tout cas je sais pas exactement ce
qu'ils vont faire mais je sais que les
parlementaires présents il ya un seul
écologiste et socialiste et républicain
se demandent quelles doivent être les
suites parlementaire sur le sujet alors
on s'intéresse effectivement nouveau
choc pétrolier avec des cours toujours
plus bas avec la chute de revenus pour
certains pays une aubaine pour les pays
consommateurs comme nous avec des
conséquences évidemment pour les
pétroliers également écouter le
président de total patrick pouyanné qui
a lancé une baisse de 20% de son
résultat l'an dernier mais il assure
qu'il sera faire face
les résultats de total reste total
résiste parce que le prix du pétrole
parce que non seulement on est dans la
production de pétrole mais aussi dans la
transformation dans le raffinage dans la
distribution
donc on est dans toute la chaîne mais en
même temps nos résultats baissent ils
ont baissé d'à peu près un peu plus de
20% cette année quand le prix du pétrole
baisse de 50 où nous résistons mais nous
verrons c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
consommateur la baisse du prix du
pétrole et pour la transition écologique
je ne suis pas bonne nouvelle parce que
il faudrait pas qu on indexe toutes nos
politiques compris environnemental
uniquement liées au prix du pétrole ce
qui est sûr c'est que quand le pétrole
est très bas c'est maintenant fait qu'il
faut faire les efforts c'est à dire que
c'est quand pétrole est très bas qu'il
faut enlever l'ensemble des aides
financières portées au pétrole c'est les
niches fiscales dead par exemple au
diesel c'est tout ce qu'ils sont les
aides au kérosène partiellement
d'activités pourquoi je dis cela parce
que si on veut comme nous y engage
l'accord que nous avons porté est signée
moment la cover créateurs se désinvestir
des activités pré taulière qui sont
extrêmement nocive à l'échelle mondiale
il faut qu'on profite de ces moments là
pour dire et ben investissons sur des
travaux d'économie d'énergie et nous
disons pas chouette c'est moins cher
donc je consomme à tout va c'est
maintenant que vous demandez l'épreuve
de mais c'est maintenant qu'on peut les
faires séquence est indolore qu'il faut
les faire et en même temps ça veut pas
simplement dire être dans le punitif
mais par exemple c'est un moment
le pétrole est peu cher qu'on peut dire
à des gens qu'on est très forte
consommation par exemple de pétrole pour
se chauffer c'est maintenant qu'il faut
investir dans des travaux
c'est maintenant qu'il faut chauffer
autrement parce que là on ad on a des
des prix extrêmement faible ils peuvent
remonter du jour au lendemain on est
très tributaire des pays producteurs et
de gestion géopolitique et c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est maintenant que notre
économie se désinvestir des industries
pétrolières pour actuelle c'est la mort
du gaz de schiste que vous condamnez
depuis toujours
vous savez julie et puis ferme mais puis
ferme à cause du coût mais aussi vous
l'avez peut-être plus aux états unis
dans plusieurs régions il ya
actuellement des six mâts répétition ils
sont liés à la fracturation hydraulique
etc y compris menace des villes et on
est exactement dans ce que nous avions
dit il ya cinq ans sur les gaz de
schiste c'est une chimère et aujourd'hui
ça des dégâts environnementaux
extrêmement important et qui ont des
dégâts qui vont au-delà de ce qui était
attendu
quand vous dites c'est maintenant qu'il
faut agir c'est ce que vous feriez si
vous étiez mines et de l'écologie a tout
de suite je pense qu'en tout cas la
personne qui aurait tellement en charge
de l'écologie doit se battre pour qu'il
y ait des arbitrages y compris sur la
prochaine loi de finances sur les
questions le feu et le viol ya elle se
bat beaucoup
elle se bat beaucoup aient compris on a
vu sur des sujets très environnementaux
je pense notamment à la question de
l'interdiction d'une d'une pollution
très forte dans les calanques de
marseille kylie kylie à ce qu'on appelle
les boues rouges lectra c'est
l'extraction des minerais
ségolène royal s'est battu jusqu'au bout
et à la meilleure d'entre eux a perdu en
tout cas en tout cas elle sait de quoi
elle parle elle a compris l écoute
mais vous savez elle dit même ce matin
sur une radio pour ça que j'ai quelques
prime avec le gouvernement c'est que
j'ai un temps d'avancé sur les sujets
écologiques mais parce qu elle les
connaît puisqu'elle est conscient de ce
qu'on nous dit mais vous savez moi j'ai
aussi travaillé que laurent fabius dans
le cadre de la coop 21
j'ai rencontré un homme qui
objectivement s'est mis à la com 21 et
au climat quand on apprécie qu'on a
commencé à prendre en charge et qui a
découvert des sondés qui m'a dit un jour
cette phrase tu sais maintenant je vais
dans des réunions et j'enrage quand
personne ne comprend les impacts du
dérèglement climatique je lui ai dis
bienvenue au club
tu découvres ce que ça veut dire d'être
écologiste mais je le dis parce que la
question climatique environnementale et
l'écologie en général
un tel impact aujourd'hui sur notre
développement et serez pose la question
de notre avenir nous en tant que pays et
en tant que développement économique
on voit aussi ce que ça pose comme
question internationale qu'il est
absolument nécessaire qu'on a une
gestion économique qu'avance justement
et on a besoin de gens comme ça qui font
cette démarche économique emmanuelle
cosse je vous parle est un petit peu du
groupe areva
vous avez vu le coût de l'enfouissement
des déchets radioactifs
ça fait partie en tout cas de s'asseoir
avec d'écouter un peu plus de 25
milliards now sur plusieurs axes et pire
que cela fait pire que ça il ya eu le
choix en france comme ça pour quoi faire
des déchets radioactifs de les enterrer
donc à bulle ogier qu'on appelle cigéo
qui est à bure il faut fixer un prix
pour que ça rentre dans les comptes
d'edf et d'areva
le prix fixé par ségolène royal et 25
milliards les rapports qui ont été
proposées pour fixer ce prix on parlait
plutôt d'une estimation à 35 milliards
et même de prix beaucoup plus important
en fonction de certaines hypothèses
je vous parle même pas du fonctionnement
sur 100 sur des milliards d'années
puisque on est sûr désormais jours
c'est pour tous que ça coûte une fortune
et c'est quoi sa flasque oh bah c'est
plus qu'un fiasco parce qu'en plus la
réalité c'est qu'on sait même pas ce
qu'on lègue aux générations futures vous
est ce que vous connaissez une autre
histoire ou en gros on engage des frais
monstrueux pour stocker quelque chose on
ne sait pas comment ça va évoluer on
espère les retraités 1 c'est ce que dit
le président vous avez vous avez oui
voilà le nucléaire à démarrer avant que
je sois né on peut toujours dit que
c'était propre mais pas de problème la
réalité c'est que ça coûte cher ça coûte
cher parce que c'est cool à de vrais
pète aujourd'hui dans le prix et ce
qu'ils avancent qui est avancé ces
dernières années c'est que nous avons pu
faire la transparence sur le vrai coût
du nucléaire
mais l'autre chose est ce que vous avez
envie vraiment de léguer à la génération
de vos arrières petits enfants
de tels déchets dont on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils seront dans jusqu'à fiasco voire
de l'incompétence mais c'est surtout que
je pense que c'est un désastre
industriel et cette expression les
panneaux avec michel sapin mais je crois
que c'est une vraie extraits sur la
question de notre dame des landes vous
l'avez abordé tout à l'heure écoutez le
président de la région et nouveau
président de la région des pays de la
loire qui milite pour la reprise des
travaux et qui en a parlé récemment à
manuel valls il m'a indiqué qu'il
restait absolument favorables
à sète hérault por qué l'aéroport non
seulement des pays de la loire mais du
grant west avec la bretagne et je sais
que jean yves le drian soutient aussi je
veux le redire ce projet aéroportuaire
il sait parfaitement qu'on ne pourra pas
commencer les travaux sans qu'il y ait
par ailleurs une évacuation ce qui s'est
engagé sur ce point mort pour l'instant
il n'est pas engagée sur le calendrier
et moi je sais très bien que là sans
doute que la décision se prendra au
dessus vraisemblablement à l'elysée je
sais que si ça dépendait de lui en tout
cas elle cherche les moyens de
réaffirmer à notre dame des landes
l'autorité de l'état qui est bafouée qui
est également président des sénateurs
socialistes qui sera notre invité les
républicains les républicains présents
des sénateurs les républicains la mère
de nortel dit que c'est au président de
la république de trancher manuel valls
il lui faut accélérer
il faut que ça attendez moi je ne parle
jamais à la place de manuel valls et je
propose que l'on ne prenne pas pour
argent comptant les propos oui par bruno
retailleau je pense qu'il est important
que les travaux je pense surtout que
c'est très maladroit d'un président de
région quel qu'il soit de parler à la
place des prévenus qu'au final quelques
mois je pense qu'il faut l'arrêter il
faut l'arrêter parce que non pas
simplement parce qu'il est très forte
mobilisation contre l'aéroport mais
parce que c'est un non sens économique
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas besoin de
cet aéroport à plusieurs de dizaines de
kilomètres de nantes dans un bocage
nantais où des gens aujourd'hui travail
on va mettre en cause des espèces
protégées et donc remettre en cause la
loi
on oublie de dire et donc je leur dis
très simplement tous les recours
juridiques ne sont pas des cas dit
françois hollande et ne fera rien tant
que les recours juridiques et là pour
l'instant les travaux ont repris les
travaux n'ont pas repris il ya la géo
vinci qui est la filiale de vinci
pfastatt aéroport qu'a décidé de faire
la guérilla juridique et de s'opposer et
d'exproprier des familles de paysans qui
ont refusé l'indemnisation il ya
plusieurs années qu'ils sont justes et
sa tante qui sont sur le site depuis nos
certains cinq générations qui vivent là
bas et qui ont été à l'origine de cette
lutte la famille frais notamment sylvain
fresneau cas eric ultor aujourd'hui son
oncle est un des premiers lanceurs de
cette lutte en 74
pourquoi je parle de cela parce qu'à un
moment il faut prendre les engagements
pour me demander des actes
jacob 21 un des axes de dire qu'on ne
fait plus d'aéroports qu'on n'en a pas
besoin
et le problème c'est que maintenant
non il faut arrêter ces tâtonnements
comment ce monsieur retailleau d'un seul
coup ça puissant manuel valls et jean
yves le drian pour porter ces projets
ils sont d'accord moi je vais vous
parler de notre président
moi j'aimerais bien que le président de
la région bretagne me dise s'il est
d'accord qu'on lui dira qu'il faut faire
mais lorient manuel coty nouvelle pour
vous parler des deux régions vous êtes
élue régionale elle a décidé de faire
une série d'anneaux jeudi et notamment
de mettre sur la table ni stone prix du
pass navigo savez ce soit parce qu'il
permet un peu partout en 1270 euros et
le dis que ça va coûter 300 millions
d'euros
vous étiez vous fer de lance sur sept
qui s'allume en allemand c'est vers vous
que ce bilan se retourne mais sauf que
je vais vous dire les choses très
simplement nous sommes battus cinq ans
pour qu'il y ait un seul tarif de
transport pour tous les franciliens 70
euros c'est une réussite sociaux de
rouyn dit c'est une réussite sociale ça
bonifie 6 à plus de quatre millions cinq
d'abonnés valérie pécresse aujourd'hui
sort ainsi de 3,6 1300 millions d'euros
sans l'étayer sans aucun chiffre nous
n'avons pas les relais chiffres de
recettes mensuelles du stif qui gère les
transports en ile de france
nous aurons le débat jeudi en séance
mais la ranimer police et à valérie
pécresse pour applaudir xavier bertrand
mais je la boda blotti n'applaudit
sûrement pas valérie pécresse qui
s'attaque à la seule grande mesure qui a
été fait dans cette région qui permet
d'avoir la mobilité merci beaucoup à
emmanuel coste merci mcee à michael et
donc la semaine prochaine c'est bruno
retailleau qui sera votre place le
patron des sénateurs les républicains
vent fera tout ça très vite
qui